hello there and welcome to Playstation
grenade it's been three long long long
weeks since we had enough content to
talk about in fortnight Battle Royale
in terms of map changes and story
updates what what week are we on right
now seven to 17 while this season is
officially the longest in history like
usual sit your butt down for 10 minutes
use code Adam are you in the fortnight
shop to keep this series going and let's
check out all the changes from the last
three weeks oh and I have a story theory
this week which talks about what's
inside that bunker this week we saw the
introduction of the chaos engine to
fortnight known for its destructive
abilities and particle physics this
update is going to be huge well in
actuality it wasn't really implemented
the crazy destruction we all foresaw
simply isn't here well not yet anyway
but this could be a slow build towards
the end of the season and that event may
be the destruction the engine is capable
of will be used to I don't know blow up
steamy stacks or crumble the mountain
with the redacted bunker to the ground
we shall see in about 10 days hopefully
unless the season is prolonged even
further there are actually a few
examples of the new engine but they are
so minut you have likely missed them
when swinging your pickaxe at a tree or
block of stone the PCs that fly from the
strike are now more visible and go in
different angles I know it's not much
but it's a little bit of evidence that
the engine is here also on top of that
you should have noticed that the capes
move more freely and just look a bit
more real in general it's not perfect
but it's definitely a huge improvement
but you're not here for that kind of
thing anyway so let's crack on
[Music]
a few months ago I showed you the king
of gnomes grahame the genome he sits on
top of the radio station tower watching
and planning his next move for global
domination maybe not
or maybe he's simply there and just
can't get down well the Radio Shack
received an update just under three
weeks ago and the construction is still
being built right now
maybe this location is receiving an
overhaul to make it more desirable as a
landing spot
I was hoping more updates would have
happened by now but not yet so let's try
again next week many people have noted
that the telescope behind the radio
tower is a clue to the end of season
event which is telling us to keep an eye
above steamy stacks what do you think
any truth there another change from back
then happened around a house in the
Greenland below the beach but above
Holly hedges this house suddenly changed
all the furniture was moved outdoors and
the floors and walls have either started
to degenerate like the house close by or
someone is starting a dig site here hmm
the last time we saw a dig site was in
chapter 1 and the search to locate the
vault hidden under loot Lake man they
were good times weren't they regular
updates are they with great so what is
going on here something are nothing fine
Yorkshire we say out-and-out hit me up
with those theories if you've got any
[Music]
the next update could happen at any time
and it's likely to begin before we meet
up again so I'm going to include some
leaks right now so if you're not into
that run away and hide right now are
they gone let's crack on in October last
year a golden toilet was stolen from an
art exhibition in the UK since then
nobody has come forward and no one has
found it the toilet has been on tour
around the world with 100,000 people
lining up to use it in New York alone
that's gross but great I have no idea
why I'm saying this in fact yes I do
because the toilet has now been found in
fortnight leakers have found the golden
porcelain in the games files which will
be appearing this week in the game it
has been narrowed down to the central
island you know the same place we fought
the storm king in fact let's stop for a
second and ask a very very important
question what's the worst thing you call
a toilet where you are in the world in
the north of England it's called a bog
yeah we're not very high class up here
I'll be definitely in the comments
looking for a giggle on this one so
slowly here at the central cabin random
items will be changing to gold such as
the sofas couches cabinets and even the
globe thing which is probably a hidden
drinks cabinet leakers fire monkey and
my favorite fort tory are both
suggesting over the next week golden
props will slowly be added to the island
but what could this be for should we
expect a character with a Midas touch or
does this link in with the golden 8-ball
skin or is this for a future event well
there's one more piece of info to look
at here an ego file it's uncertain where
this will appear but yes it definitely
could be here on the toilet
maybe they needed some light reading
before dropping the kids off at the pool
this might be pivotal to the story
whether they become collectible items
in-game to unlock a skin like the old
singularity quest or maybe there will be
pieced together information kinda like
the visitors audio tapes either way
let's keep an eye out for these see who
can find them first if you spot anything
please hit me up on twitter i'm adam
granade over there and my DMS are always
open I think that's all the updates you
know let's just check one more spot
house watch has not moved in the
slightest even the magical floating
doorbell remains here we were promised
this would be a quick build but to last
this erection is taking three weeks
already I don't have the time for this
fYI you've already seen this house
completed in the loading screen
it's hardly there look just there just
there Wow but when will it be finished
in game this season we shall see many of
you have asked for another story theory
last week I made a video going over the
general changes the general feel of what
the season is but this week I have been
researching GI Joe you heard me right a
grown adult man in the UK what she's a
TV show for children to make them sign
up for the US Armed Forces I have issues
we'll check this theory out and let's
see how long it takes for some
half-assed youtuber to pretend they
discovered this it'll definitely happen
but let's move on anyway when chapter 2
began we all noticed the similarities to
GI Joe especially Snake Eyes and shadow
Dom looking like 8-ball and scratch well
let's first look at those two in GI Joe
these two were almost brothers training
alongside each other under their sensei
something happened which corrupted
shadows Dom who killed their master
beginning a feud to last a lifetime
in fortnight shadow storms look alike
scratch is now corrupting hmm sticking
with this there is a story bombshell to
come other characters have striking
resemblances to the Cobra Commander
looks a great deal like stingray toxin
is a play on the Baroness neo-viper
looks to have inspired the current metal
style skins and the similarities go on
and on we know that Fortnight loves to
take other people's content let me
rephrase that
we know that Fortnight loves to pay
homage to other creative creations who
got out of that one so I decided to
watch the latest GI Joe cartoon to see
if the story was taken from there to the
cartoon was cancelled by the way and is
completely unavailable in the UK so this
was a tough find check this out GI Joe
renegades leaves behind the usual themes
of GI Joe
makes the heroes on the run from the law
they are suddenly attacked by these
creatures which have been created by a
combination of nature and a little
science meddling at this point I'm
hoping you're thinking hey that's Ripley
but he's evil a point to note here is
that he isn't evil
or it isn't evil it's just really dumb
does what it's told it's like a
schoolyard bully strong but dumb the
gels tried to fight these in many
different ways they build Excel soups
kind of like the mechs last season and
that doesn't go too well long story
short they find that pesticides do the
trick so what about the bud guys where
are they during all this they are held
up and get this a secret bunker sounds
familiar right and over 26 episodes we
try to figure out what's inside that
bunker and finally on the 26th episode
they break into the redacted bunker and
an epic battle ensues and now it's time
to reveal what they were hiding in that
bunker it's none other than a
teleportation unit hmm allowing users to
deconstruct themselves and reconstruct
in another location here's what's really
interesting here this tech already
exists in fortnight remember back in
whaling woods and the bunkers each one
had a rift to travel to the cabins this
is the same tech in the bunker of the GI
Joes could this mean the new optimized
engine in fortnight will allow us to
rift to other areas of the map to
improve mobility I believe the reason we
don't already have this is due to the
previous engine used and the devices we
all play on the amount of data we need
to be crunched to allow this is quite
staggering but we've already seen it
does work we had the portable rifts so
it's definitely possible and would
improve the game tenfold anyway I'm
getting sidetracked back to the GI Joes
at the end of the series the squad wins
the battle but the problem is the bunker
is going to explode so they race out of
there they just get out in the nick of
time and everything goes boom what if
this happens in fortnight
maybe the mountain may be steamy stacks
I cannot wait to see if the chaos engine
can help do something like this anyway
I'm blabbing far too much here so what's
your feeling on that theory warrior
reckon how could fortnight add to this
basic story I do hope we see the chaos
engine do
something monumental guys if you've
stayed this long you are officially my
best friend in the whole wide world I
also want to thank these people
on-screen now from the bottom of my
heart for continuing to support me even
though I don't have much more tonight
content out at the moment you honestly
are complete leggings to me thank you
for using code and amaru it means the
world to me if you spot anything in
fortnight or use my code to buy
something please make sure you DM me on
Twitter I missed so many of the posts
you tagged me in so pretty pretty please
use my DMS that way you know I will see
them thank you so much for your time
hopefully we'll have another update next
week it's been an absolute pleasure
much love see you next time